now let's draw three circles and generic
circles that are separated like this in
space given a pair of circles for
example large and middle you can draw a
common tangent to those two circles like
so and like so to be precise we are
drawing two outer tangents because you
can cross these like this a tangent and
tangent to the inner tangents that cross
but let's talk about the outer tangents
and those two other tangents be these
circles are usually of different sizes
we'll meet at the vertex or tip which
I'll mark black dot and because they're
three pairs large and middle middle and
small and small large there are three
pairs of tangents and the theorem is
that if you take the tip of the first
pair heap of the second pair of tangents
and tip of the third pair of tangents
they are all aligned along the straight
line what the chance is the three
arbitrary points on a plane aligned
along the straight line zero but in this
case they do align very very beautifully
along a straight line this theorem goes
back as far as I know to French
mathematician engineer called Monch one
of the founders very cool technique in
Paris and he was very famous for
descriptive geometry and humbly and
ablai so the how to move a pile of stuff
from here to there minimizing energy and
cost and that kind of research but he
also has a few contributions in
elementary geometry like this and this
is improvable by different methods for
example minerals and so forth we'll do
it in a classical method but there's a
very very beautiful approach which again
has to do with lifting the whole picture
to the three dimensions instead of those
three circles let's imagine that these
are actually pictures of three spheres
as seen from above please imagine that
those three spheres are sitting on the
same table in other words their centers
are different heights
large one will be lifted a lot and the
small one will be lifted only a small
amount the middle one a little middle
ish but they're all sitting on the same
tables given say a large bowl and the
middle ball you can
draw a common tangent cone so cone like
an ice cream cone so something that
surface like this which sort of expands
and which so the shrink shrink shrink to
a tip and if you look at that picture
from above you see what we saw before
that is two circles and pair of common
tangent lines and the tip so you can
interpret that picture as actually a
three-dimensional picture but see in two
dimensional appearance okay and because
there are three balls large and middle
will have a cone and the tip middle and
small will have a cone and tip and small
and large cone on tip you have three
tips of those three cones on the other
hand please imagine again those three
spheres sitting on a common floor and
now if you please take a transparent
ceiling from above and just tilt it tilt
it and just lower it so that it touches
those three spheres at the same time
from above you have to tilt it yeah it's
not you can't be horizontal you have
thetan it touches those three spheres at
the same time so you have now a ceiling
which touches those three spheres from
above and the flow which touches those
three spheres from below each of those
cones that we talked about for example
this cone between large and middle fear
well it's touching this ceiling and the
floor at the same time this cone so the
tip of this cone is inside the ceiling
and inside the floor at the same time
okay and the same goes for the other two
tips so all those tips of the cones in
the top plane that is the ceiling and
the bottom plane that is floor at the
same time but you know those two planes
in space intersect along a straight line
so we have just shown that those tips of
cones along a straight line and which
what is that straight line it's the
intersection of the ceiling that we put
from above and the flow on which you put
the bolts and if you look at that
picture from above you see this picture
so that dotted line is the intersection
of the seedings which is tipping like
that and then the flow which is
supporting the thing
you know you can also see a cartoon you
just lift this and and that's the
seeding pie primetime you know then the
flow is pie and then the common cone
tangent cone to these two spheres is
like that and tip is lying in the
intersection intersecting line between
the ceiling and the floor okay so by
lifting the this complicated problem to
the third dimension the problem goes
away in fact if you look at it the right
way you know there used to be one of
those interesting pictures where you
look at it with some out-of-focus sight
suddenly it jumps out to you into a 3d
and it's a bit reckless if you look at
it the right way you can start seeing it
like a three-dimensional picture and
then the theorem is clear there is no
problem I mean of course these three
points must be on the same line because
that's how I see
this is actually a sequel to a previous
video with the professor about
earthquakes and spheres hopefully you've
caught that one too or if you just want
to see more videos with the professor
click on the link that's on the screen
or in the video description and while
you're in the video description you'll
find details about these numberphile
playing cars which are coming soon
[Music]